lange warteschlange im terminal genervte
flugreisende
stundenlanges anstehen vor der
sicherheitskontrolle die bilder in
diesen tagen von deutschen flughäfen
ähneln sich düsseldorf
hamburg frankfurt
fluggäste brauchen im sommer 20 22
starke nerven
hannover airport mitten in der
ferienzeit ein urlauber video die
warteschlange vor der
sicherheitskontrolle geht fast bis ins
nächste terminal die reisenden sind oft
schon stunden vorher da viele haben sich
darauf eingestellt
[Musik]
und dann halt
für die sicherheit personal wurde ja
über krone eingespart und jetzt fehlt es
natürlich an allen ecken und enden für
uns blöd aber für die eigentlich für die
leute für die es eigentlich blöd sind
die leute die arbeiten so das ist ja
heute sind ja total unterbesetzt das
problem zu wenig personal bei der
sicherheitskontrolle die überprüfung
eine hoheitliche aufgabe outgesourced
schon vor jahren von der bundespolizei
securitas ein privates unternehmen ist
hier am flughafen hannover dafür
zuständig wir sind verabredet mit einer
langjährigen mitarbeiterin des
dienstleisters sie möchte unerkannt
bleiben die haben uns im prinzip ins
offene messer laufen lassen es ist
wirklich so dass personal geht und es
kommt kein neues personal nach und wir
kriechen auf dem zahnfleisch aktuell
arbeiten hier rund 320 mitarbeiter im
schichtdienst es waren mal gut 450
berichtet die gewerkschaft werden die
pandemie hat viele in andere jobs
getrieben die verbliebenen müssen die
situation aus baden und kommen an ihre
grenzen ich komme sechs tage arbeitet
zehn stunden am stück habe eine
dreiviertel stunde pause beziehungsweise
wenn es neun stunden sind habe ich eine
halbe stunde pause in der ich nicht
schaffe im prinzip schlinge ich im
laufen mein brot und wasser runter und
wenn ich pech habe werde ich draußen vor
den terminals noch angepöbelt dass ich
doch hier nichts zu suchen hätte und
vielleicht eher dafür sorgen sollte dass
die flüge abgefertigt werden die secure
itas angestellte arbeitet seit jahren am
flughafen elf personen besetzen
normalerweise eine kontroll spur
berichtet sie durch personalknappheit
und einen oft hohen krankenstand seien
es an manchen tagen aber nur sieben
kollegen ein mitarbeiter übernehme dann
oft zwei positionen dadurch war
natürlich schnell abgefertigt werden
muss haben wir extremen druck diese
massen zu bewältigen und das es
eigentlich gar nicht machbar zwei
positionen gleichzeitig zu besetzen weil
wir sicherheit produzieren und ich bin
der meinung die sicherheit bleibt
dadurch einfach auf der strecke und es
ist nicht in ordnung
wir versuchen zum unternehmens securitas
kontakt aufzunehmen doch vor der kamera
äußert sich niemand das statement kommt
schriftlich die meisten ihrer fragen
betreffen sicherheitsrelevante themen zu
denen wir leider keine angaben machen
können beziehungsweise bei denen nur
unser kunde direkt entscheiden kann was
er beantworten kann und was nicht geht
da es vertraulich oder
sicherheitsrelevant ist der kunde in
diesem fall die bundespolizei lässt den
vorwurf dass bei den kontrollen wegen
personalknappheit möglicherweise die
sicherheit auf der strecke bliebe nicht
stehen die teile in keinster weise
es ist ja bei uns bei der bundespolizei
so dass wir entsprechend auch
aufsichtskräfte haben das heißt also wir
haben auch hinter den kontrollstellen
kontroll oder der polizeibeamte die
genau das überwachen was wir immer den
einheitlichen controls maßstab einhalten
das ist für uns ein elementarer baustein
sechs tage zehn stunden immer
unterschiedliche schichtzeiten viele
sind schon gegangen weil für familie und
privatleben kaum zeit bleibt es geht den
kollegen ähnlich weil man gefühlt
einfach nur noch für den flughafen da
ist und zum schlafen nach hause fährt
bei zehn stunden was bleibt noch und es
geht allen so und alle sind einfach
wirklich am ende
es gibt auch kein anderes thema mehr als
die arbeitsbedingungen an diesem
flughafen
der traumjob am airport lange vorbei die
behörden und der flughafen versuchen das
angekratzte image aufzupolieren
die abläufe seien schon besser heißt es
das problem sei erkannt und der
flughafen chef bittet die reisenden
mitzuhelfen vorbereitet zu sein und
alles wie früher zur hand haben wie vor
corona
nur die richtigen dinge im handgepäck
und zwei bis zweieinhalb stunden vorher
prozent mehr ist nicht notwendig hilft
auch nicht dann stehen sie nur am ende
der schlange und warten dann zwei drei
vier stunden bis sie dann beim check-in
mal dran sind dass das bringt nichts ob
das hilft fest steht in den sommerwochen
wird das hohe arbeitspensum bleiben
entspannung frühestens zum herbst ob
unsere mitarbeiterinnen dann noch den
einstigen traum job ausübt offen auch
sie überlegt zu wechseln
[Musik]